nous voici aujourd'hui sous le pont vinh
san pond très haut qui majestueusement
enjambe la rivière saint denis et relie
l'ouest de l'île et la montagne au
chef-lieu un pont entre l'orient et
l'occident en somme tout un symbole à
l'image de celui dont il porte le nom
mais qui s'en souvient aujourd'hui est
ce que vous savez qu'ils étaient d'une
femme vélo la marche de l'auto nous
sommes cette impasse et un chinois
en france sur le sujet qui a fait la
guerre sa famille vinh-san c'est en fait
le prénom du dernier empereur d'annam
l'actuel vietnam à son accession au
trône le 5 septembre 1907 le roi d'hui
tan qui veut dire amis des réformes n'a
donc sept ans anin mais alors sous
protectorat français il succède à son
propre père obligé d'abdiquer parce que
trop rebelle mais en 1916 le jeune
vinh-san accusé à son tour d'avoir
fomenter une révolte contre les français
est exilé sur la lointaine réunion le 20
novembre 1916 commence donc une seconde
vie avec sa petite pension versée par
l'indochine vinh salle est un excellent
jockey un bon violoniste un écrivain de
talent et même un homme politique
francophile convaincue et radio amateur
il décrypte l'appel du général de gaulle
le 18 juin 1940 il partage aussi tôt le
message de ce général qui commune
accepte pas l'occupation étrangère de
son pays pour l'opération léopard du 28
novembre 1942 c'est lui nom de code est
faire vite vx qui sert de relais aux
forces françaises libres sur le point de
débarquer engagé dans les forces
françaises libres il est nommé chef de
bataillon en 1945 alors qu'il rejoint la
réunion son avion s'écrase dans des
circonstances mystérieuses à 100 km de
bangui en centrafrique
il n'avait jamais abdiqué la dépouille
du dernier empereur d'annam que repose
depuis 1987 sur sa terre natale